Director Ang Lee's Gemini Man has been screened
for critics, and it blew their faces right
off.
Just when you thought movie magic had reached
its pinnacle, critics are calling it a new
landmark in visual effects.
Based on the movie's plot about a hired killer
who is stalked by a younger clone of himself,
observers have been quick to draw comparisons
between Gemini Man and another recent flick,
the name of which escapes us.
Just kidding - it's Rian Johnson's 2012 film
Looper, which sports a similar premise.
But Gemini Man has actually been in development
for over 20 years.
The first script for the film was completed
in 1997, and at that time, it was to be directed
by the late Top Gun director, Tony Scott.
Originally, the idea was to have different
actors play the older and younger versions
of the main character, like they did in Looper,
but once producers decided to have the same
actor play both parts, the wait for technology
to catch up began.
Well, that technology is finally here, and
director Ang Lee goes hog wild, using cutting
edge motion capture technology to render the
younger version of Smith.
"I play both 50-year-old Henry and 23-year-old
Junior, who is sent to kill him."
And Lee also shot the film at 120 frames per
second rather than the typical 24 in order
to give it a sense of visceral realism.
The result, according to virtually every critic
who has been lucky enough to feast their eyes
on the movie, is nothing short of mind-blowing.
A common thread among their remarks: this
is the first film in years that you will definitely,
absolutely, positively have to see in 3-D.
Engadget editor Devindra Hardawar positively
gushed over the film in a series of tweets.
"Vibrating from excitement after seeing Gemini
Man.
It uses 120FPS and 3D to create some of the
most exciting action sequences I've seen in
years.
Happy to see Ang Lee return to action, the
choreography feels intense because it looks
so realistic."
He added,
"The script is a bit generic, but I think
the visuals and Smith's performance overcomes
it.
In terms of groundbreaking visual experiments,
this feels as important as Avatar."
That's a very bold statement, but other critics
agreed that Gemini Man is arguably the first
film since Avatar that requires you to see
it in 3-D to really get the full experience.
Syfywire feature editor Jordan Zakarin said
"Just saw the final cut of Ang Lee's #GeminiMan
and it's probably the only movie I'd ever
say absolutely must be seen in 3D (and 4K,
if possible).
I've never seen anything like it it felt like
I was inside the movie."
The sentiment was echoed by Refinery29 senior
editor Anne Cohen, who wrote,
"Just saw #GeminiMan and it's wiiiiiiild.
The young version of Will Smith is incredible,
plus some truly beautiful action sequences
and a really great performance by Mary Elizabeth
Winstead.
The only 3D movie I'll ever endorse."
Fandango managing editor Erik Davis agreed
that it needed to be seen in 3-D, and also
highlighted how much detail went into making
the film.
"There's one scene in #GeminiMan where old
Smith and young Smith have an all-out brawl
with one another.
It's pretty amazing to watch.
I asked Ang Lee how they executed that sequence,
and he said it was so involved it took 9 months
to complete.
9 months for a fight scene!"
Meanwhile, Yahoo!
Entertainment senior writer Ethan Alter focused
on the film's groundbreaking use of a super
high frame rate.
"Even high-frame rate skeptics may be converted
by what Ang Lee pulls off in #GeminiMan.
While not seamless, it's probably the strongest
argument for HFR photography I've seen, and
the illusion actually gets better as the movie
goes along."
The lovefest was perhaps summed up best by
ComingSoon.net senior editor Max Evry:
"Ang Lee's #GeminiMan is a huge breakthrough
for 120FPS presentation.
Action sequences are breathtaking in this
format.
Will Smith's winning performance shows the
level of scrutiny a real movie star can stand
up to.
If you don't see it in theaters you're missing
a true experience."
"Action"
"Ooh, s---.
That's crazy!!"
All the praise on the film's technical details
is fantastic, but it's Collider's Vinnie Mancuso
who really cuts to the chase and tells you
what you truly need to know:
"In Gemini Man, the young Will Smith throws
not one, but two (2) motorcycles at the old
Will Smith and that, to me, is very good.
Highly recommend."
Okay, we're sold.
We'll see you in line when Gemini Man hits
the big screen on October 11.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.